John immediate it Tom Laurie I'm
pregnant was in the middle of connecting
yeah you know live chair yeah you're
muted P okay I'm not I'm on that okay
yes yeah first of all thank you all for
for turning up it looks a nice good
turnout no problem at all I have to read
out one or two things one I would like
to welcome you all to this virtual
meeting then and then internal Overman
scrutiny meeting out on the center June
2020 I will just go through some basic
rules for this meeting other started
meets in please mute your microphones
and leave them mutant unless you I asked
him by me to speak to indicate to me
that you would like to speak or propose
or second emotion please press the
raised and the raise the hand symbol in
the part of the participants menu on
your screen we we're all okay with that
yeah these are shown on my screen in
order and they are pressed and I will
deal with them in order given the
appropriate officer or counselor the
opportunity to answering between when
necessary I also will also return to the
council to check that they are happy
with the response to ensure clarity and
to see during virtual meetings all votes
will be cast by a verbal recorded vote
and names will be read out in
alphabetical order prease state you'll
net your vote clearly and slowly when
your name is read out unmuting and
muting your microphone as necessary and
just one little thing on that when we
have to go to a vote I would like you
all to be prepared to do that as you
know I know we've had little problems
before with other meetings but if you
could be prepared ready to unmute to me
that would be great
please remember that to ensure full
transparency that with the democratic
process this meeting is being
live-streamed on counts on councils
YouTube channel I understand we're in
unprecedented times but I'm sure we will
we will do ok with this meeting and
future meetings now I'll go on to the
main agenda just to let you know Kayla
Haines is just joining the meeting all
right ok thank you right okay first of
all apologies for absence Mary Jo
polishes from counsel about and
councillor Harding is substituting right
Thank You
minutes of the last meeting I I would
think take it that you've all read the
minutes of the last meeting and what
I'll do I'll go through the pages one at
a time
page 3 page 4 page 5 page 6 and page 7
could I have a proposal please and
second right proposer
is councillor manly and secondary
councillor Newton will now do this thing
called voting so Mary over to you please
and silicon honking mr. Deng gate for
cancer look up for councillor Haynes
Colonel Haynes mu Council arranged for
canceled Harding abstain mr. Harper
cancel the Lankford for councillor manly
Oh
councilman yeah
councilman Newton Oh
councillor Watson that's ten four and
one abstention
thank you Mary we now go to page eight
on the agenda which is the action list
minute 69 you can read the response
there before this and then that we've
got many 56 ethical investment sorry
Stephen dengue would like to speak on
mute leave and say thank you just say
that we we've got it down as a quick
lesson I think we were going to look at
PSG which is environmental social and
governance by definition rather than
ethical okay thanks for that Oh we'll
we'll look into that
Steve thanks very much and I've got
nothing else on on the action list
so then we'll move on now to public
contributions well I have got no public
wanted to speak so we'll move on from
there declarations of interest
by now you all understand about
declarations of interest and so well if
we do come to an item where you need to
declared then please do so when we
before the item age of my portfolio the
permission of the chair I haven't got
any age of matters agreement of the
gender parts 1 & 2 we've got no pot - so
we're now way onto item number 8 which
is potentially a study found that oh
sorry sorry
council rates yes just ago just to go
back to item 6 check and if you just
like I didn't know where else to bring
this up okay with with the lockdown be
knees now and the pubs open and the and
the and the restaurants be it open I
wonder if there Steve or somebody else
there could them were the officers
produc I'd ask when we will come back to
meeting in a proper way again because
you know a small group like this can be
tonnato at all and still be 1 plus
meters away I was wondering what plans
are for us to do that now because the
lockdown easy is easy and you know if we
could go in a pub to drink surely we can
meet in the town or to have a meetin
Thank You Jerry
Dave yeah I'll come back come back on
that one if you like
currently the legislation doesn't permit
us to meet in that format Aussie members
will have seen that Parliament is sit in
so I asked they see to have a look into
that to see if there's different rules
and yes they that for falls under a
different set of legislation I
understand doing back some centuries ago
that permits them to meet so currently
as comes Lynch quite rightly said if you
know you're able to go into pubs and
different restaurants and so forth
but we're not currently able and
ordinary council committee meetings as
yet the LGA are kind of lobbying for
that to happen and i think i circulated
some information to members recently in
terms of whether there could be some
kind of hybrid meeting so some members
presents others joined in by zoom yes
comes will intercept a meeting of this
size it could be possible in terms of
social distance in but then if you've
got members of the the public coming in
because it's an open meeting that would
obviously cause further difficulties and
certainly for the larger committee
meetings such as full council that would
be not possible in the town hall so it's
something we watching and following
closely and will update members as soon
as more information is available
[Music]
counselor ain't you're happy with that
yeah quite happy okay okay very clear
okay i'm slowly because this hand ups
chair sorry councillor Newton has his
hand up chair oh sorry I'm not
concentrating castle in Newton where are
you Thank You chair if I could just add
as a quick carrier follow-on to that I
know it's not our core business that
that uh it's being to Steve I very much
hope that whatever we end up with in a
future when we do return to live
sittings also incorporates lessons that
we've learned from this time and we can
therefore engage digitally with the
wider community so that our future
muting meetings at least are also on
YouTube and indeed that councillors
perhaps who aren't committee members may
still be able to join virtually because
eating without doubt increases the level
of interest and a number of people who
join up of seedings and we've really got
to connect with the way that people
communicate nowadays thank you
right okay can move on Malan please okay
we're going on to item 8 now the QPR
what for pages 19 to 20 and I believe
we're going to have a report of by the
interim faith service or is it going to
be David Lee's chair I think Kris and
grazes will be leading a presentation
okay it's not some of the key details
that's fine
okay Kris where you go okay good morning
everybody
there's you know QPR fall in fact
Assembly of the castle's performance
over the full 12 months mmm it's just a
short presentation to go to the
performance highlights then David Hayes
will go through the financial highlights
and then we've got a very comprehensive
Q&A document to go through so this first
slide go on looking at our economy I'll
just think through a few highlights on
this page first one there
the Lucas filled with car park was
completed in West with her she's an IT
project on time and in budget
extra car parking spaces for us to he'll
cut stone blue construction was
completed again on on time I think we've
got three or four units occupied or
waiting just for the lockdown to finish
with it for the final units the actually
fund they do sell is ongoing I think
we're looking at kind of 5 million Palm
Beach for Biddeford is what they're
looking for and the another think one
last year was the approves a golf
contract signed obviously this is
something where most people have benefit
have seen this kind of I saw for their
lives you know it's quite exciting that
we cope with Fanny co-movement supposed
to quaff that's a really good use of
benefit in terms of performance measures
we've only really used the unemployment
level so the cons of the next slide if
you look at the last kind of several
years in terms of an employment the
Green Line is the national level the red
line is Southwest level and the blue
line is targes level so actually over
the last kind of four five or six years
didn't prama level in charges been low
actually being below the southwest of
below its there's been kind of a quite a
good picture of the last few years we
don't know what's going to happen with
them the co vid because there's a like a
six-month time lag so we get data we do
know that in the southwest universal
accreditation of the world during
lockdown I think you South hams are
gonna form 2% so we'll start to get a
picture at the end of next week
of what's happening probably October
before we got a full picture of what the
impact has been on our employment rates
but it is likely to start going up
throughout the next slide please
go to look at our healthy communities
again some good things this cell year
the community grant scheme control
conclusion was another 74 Cade and the
other 20 projects going on so with the
council of glasses 140 K going to arts
community projects which again is
excellence the new skate park opened
last summer
we've got she also purchased a couple of
properties conversions temple
accommodation and want a bit of it with
an apple door which is if she could move
just as a possum their affordable homes
delivery kick actually increased them
last year on the year before but he's
still much lower than requirements if
you've got an extra in terms of
performance measures what I've picked
out was our households in temporal
accommodation as you can see so this is
kind of remained high it does increase
its remain time she's still a problem
area for the council because putting
people in temple accommodation is
expensive it does remain a problem
basically we have insufficient social
housing in the area we have very high
social events and I know we've got so
this is kind of coming up in our Q&A
session there's quite a few questions on
this it is a recognized problem for the
council it is quite costly
so can move on go through some of our
quality environments and the first one
there last year the council they tried a
climate emergency and we set up a
Climate Action Group the castle's got
quite a good history already in doing
things green things in terms of energy
efficiency for our buildings
helping so long wind farms and but it's
good moves oh she's taking this on to
the next level and doing more things a
big thing master was I've exactly made
increase to 54% she's really really good
achievement for the council a garden
waste subscriptions went up here on here
to 12 for this year he's running at
twelve six six three and she talks about
thirteen thousand this year so again
that's it that's a good good thing and
also we didn't install some electric
charging pipes now car parks as well
we've got some stats on that in the Q&A
session
on the next slide it's [ __ ] here
picked our recycling figures the last 13
years you can see that really for a long
time we we were struggling to get above
a certain level and the goodman has had
a target 50 percent by 2020 you can see
the step change there when we introduced
our waste review was a significant step
change upwards the last two years has
been significantly better and we are
growing well now the draft figures for
quarter one this year it's looking about
57 percent which is obviously better but
I think that's based on Amazon cardboard
boxes and wine bottles coming out sensor
and people's wine box to the black crate
so no comment we are looking like care
of things and still which is great news
I'm to go for it's not crystal focus
Council when I plication is determined
in time continues to improve appeals
decide in our favor was again it
improves another improvement there this
is to the customer hope was down 24
percent last year which was kind of an
impact of our transforming charge
program this two numbers have been going
down about 10% a year for rust then
about 10 years there's a big downward
shift last year when we closed down
bridge buildings this is kind of born up
from the fact that people we are seeing
our numbers to website go help
considerably seeing our email traffic
going up considerably so people are
actually accessing the castle services
digitally now so we can improve the
website further now stepping the way
forward and I can see now that after
lockdown
those numbers coming in will get a lot
further I think now a fan of the freedom
information requests again an increased
sevens in a sixty last year so we're
getting 50 Oh 15 to 20 a week in now
which is kind of quite a considerable
number so this is kind of got up every
single year since it came in and it just
it just plays quite a burden on the
council we are doing them
99 percent last year in time so Grand
Festival actually still doing that in
time then on the next slide I picked out
them I should complete it on time so we
remember two or three or four years ago
the planning team was criticized quite a
lot but actually been quite solid
consistent improvements and this is kind
of borne out in the fact we are doing
know a little tonight shot thus ends on
time now and within this thing and it's
actually not even fair that you in
lockdown so it's cry success story in
our planning team I think there needs to
recognize definitely does gonna attach a
it's gone up to 100 percent during
lockdown yeah which is amazing yeah of
Hugh David
thank you some of the key points of the
financial year 2019-20
we understand by 150 1000 pounds and the
recommendation into community resources
that this is the transition in
government funded reserve to meet the
pressures of coal bid 19 there wasn't
really any impact on our finances in
2019 from coal big 19 because the lock
down essentially came towards the end of
the financial year in towards the end of
March okay so the main areas have
underspend Chris's already referred to
homelessness well we understand by a
hundred nine thousand pounds and this is
reduced use of tempo combination however
members need to be aware that we
actually over 200,000 pounds additional
to the 2019 20 budgets so whilst we
understand against the budget it needs
to be recognized just how large a
resource is committed to our budgets in
respect to homelessness and particularly
the issue we still have were Tempe
accommodation and finding suitable
accommodation to move people on from in
terms of staffing that's the big
everyone spent four hundred seven seven
thousand we had refuge the new roughly
rounds that was surprising when we
change our recycling would move now to
task and finish so as soon as the crews
are returned to the depo they can finish
and there's been some settling in and
during this year we've managed to sort
of sort out the issue and essentially
that's massively reduced our overtime
expenditure obviously as Chris has
alluded to earlier we're now working
from one side so we're having savings on
our customer services team so from
working from one site Housing Benefit
there's been a move toward universal
credit particularly for people of
working age so if they consist of arisen
throughout the Housing Benefit team have
not been filled and that's we've
generated some financial savings there
in terms of the customer services and
housing benefits salary savings
they've already been incorporated into
the 2020 120 but see about 2021 budgets
these over vacancies as well throughout
the council
to amount to about 2% of our staff in
budgets next slide please
mayonnaise understanding in continued
business rate income ah we've got
additional section 31 grant from
government because we've an extended
release to businesses essentially
businesses pay less money and we're
compensated by section 31 ground from
the government's refuge as Chris is
alluded to we've increased our recycling
rates
we're actually financially incentivized
for doing so and we go for increased
recycling tonnages so we get both
recycle and credits and cost share cost
share being where we sharing the benefit
to Devon County Council because they're
less waste into landfill essentially the
refuge and recycling team also quite
significant under spends on transport
related matters and that's primarily due
to lower fuel prices
weari tended for our insurance and that
generates it as saviors of 81,000 we
always every year we have a contingency
reserve 70,000 and we didn't really
utilize it in 2019 went on to spend only
some significant under spend on
additional income you see from the
crematorium which we as a joint
operation with North Devon Council I am
car parking and rental another income
and that slide please so in 2000 1920 we
spent 5 million pounds roughly our
capital and these are the major areas
expansion they're listed there for you
was true
we're going on through all and zoom now
we're on a new IT infrastructure that
were rolling out I spent about 500,000
there's some replacement vehicles in
Richards area obviously we did delivered
the Wilkie's contracts we redid with the
caps down the new office accommodation
escape we spent over just about 1.2
million on disabled facilities
adaptations and energy efficient boilers
that's funded from the better care
funding that we received via Devon
County
and as Chris alluded to we purchase two
new accommodations to help us with our
homelessness issue next slide please
our remark reserves are declined by two
million pounds during 2000 1920s it
basically could be used our reserves to
me Catholics Pena as we planned see the
council's average rate of return on its
temporary investments is was one point
zero five percent just don't you know
that significantly less now with the but
recent Bank of England base rate cuts
the county council's cash balances at
the close of two thousand ninety twenty
were ten point nine will be six million
pounds lodged with financial
institutions of six million and winning
a bank account four point nine million
the corresponding figures at starting a
financial year two thousand nineteen
twenty were thirteen point four million
and as I said the Duchess primary due to
the capital expenditure incurred during
the year next slide
at the end of the present any questions
Oh blimey that was good David any hello
yes any questions for David obviously
not but that's extremely good nobody
sounds up okay okay we'll have a look at
the advanced questions now we got from
from this qbr but okay have you got a
list of them there John online
no no chair we have them okay right okay
well I think Mary email all these out
yesterday and I'm sure you all have gone
through them with real intent don't put
your hand up features pressure press you
blue button yeah
participants if you want to speak
you pay you you can speak now what can
you hear me yeah I can eat you but if
you want if you want me you must you
must put your gone to participants and
put your hand up
okay sorry Bella yeah I just think it's
a shame we haven't got the questions and
answers on the screen really will be
much easier for us to talk about them
well have you not have you not printed
him off um well I started printing them
off while I was trying to get on to the
zoo meeting bun fortune there is 11
pages yeah I've got some of them here
yeah okay thanks
right what I intend to do is I'll go
through the list of questions and
answers page by page and anybody that
would like to make a comment about any
of them on that particular page I need
you to put your hand up so we can go to
whichever you want to do okay I went
looking now at page one I'll get okay
council a new turn what would you like
to know
from what sorry chair my my hand went up
before you started going through page by
page question because these aren't on
screen have these questions be be are
they visible to the general public have
they had an opportunity to see these and
ask passes jumbo I need you to come in
here John I'm not sure about that
answered they they have another moment
but they will be published alongside the
minute at the time so people will be
able to see what was asked and what was
what the answers were okay fine
that answer your question Simon
councillor Newton sorry I must call you
counselor because we're on YouTube quite
right chair be well yes it's tight
slightly illogical if people
to follow this meeting when they can't
actually see what we've been now what
we're discussing I'm okay fine I'm
disappointed we can't get those up did
you want to ask a question about any of
the questions and answers on page one
No okay we'll move on cattle cattle and
kin sure common questions and I haven't
got page numbers on my questions I don't
know if other people are the same
I'm just looking at it on the email and
it's just one long list of questions and
answers yeah well okay it will it will
be near the top of that which will be on
the first page right I printed him off
of my company off of my email and it
comes up with patient and was at the
bottom okay that's fine I just haven't
got page numbers of mine but yeah that's
fine right anything out no mr. den gate
thank you and just don't go 1 Brunswick
wolf thank you to a gym for the answers
on that I just wonder if we can find a
way to keep progress in visibility so
that we can be seeing what's happening
because it's a good timeline could be
very good if if we can ensure its kind
of tracked alongside that okay bye
they join me to respond to that yes I
guess it'll be picked up in each of your
quarterly reports because it's part of
the the main performance reports or when
you get quarter one report at the next
meeting if there is any progress it'll
be reported alongside that and equally
as it's done following each meter and so
if there are any particular questions
but you're forthcoming meeting members
could pick that I guess it might just be
worth adding in terms of the questions
being on the screen what we might need
to do if we are continuing by a zoom as
as we will do its current play is
perhaps sending out the questions
earlier and sending out see the stuff
earlier and
we're in questions back earlier because
obviously these are only finalized late
yesterday so then trying to get them all
into a presentation for a meeting first
thing in the morning it's kind of
challenging so we might be that we have
the questions published on this on the
screen but not necessarily answer or
just a little bit of a summary well
we're gonna have a look at that next for
next time chair yeah that's fine Steve
yeah I I think actually we should
probably try and get these questions at
least a couple of days earlier than what
we're doing because this is remarkable
to 11 pages of questions which we I
don't think we've ever had before
okay Castle Eames you've got your hand
up yeah thank you thank you very much
for doing the work to answer all the
questions I mean such a short time I
agree that we should have four questions
on the screen and future also chair when
you go through the questions can you
possibly refer to the title of the
question like torrington pena market or
whatever because I'm looking at it on my
emails and I can't see any page numbers
so it'd be easy if you clarified what it
was about
I've got a question about the response
to my work in progress about Cleve wood
there's 20% affordable has been now what
can you just wait one minute we got
we're still on the first page well I'm
making progress it obviously comes on
the next page which you've got a
question in there for yeah specify what
the title of the question is yeah I will
do that okay lankan thank you I've got a
question about the pannier market but it
seemed that angel Adrian Redbirds who's
not actually present at the meeting
that's not on page one though is it yes
sir it's a first
one chair oh sorry yeah I thought we'd
gone past that fine no no yeah if it
comes with a [ __ ] you must ask a
question sure now in the meeting if we
can under search we will if we can't
we'll take it away and prepare a
response
okay I've spoken to the traders for
pannier market I know they're part way
through the revamp and they're hoping
they're wondering if there's plans for
bigger hoppers to take a bigger volume
of water they're concerned that they're
too small to take the water when and
they're still flooding issues also
questions about when the new lighting is
going in and when Toyoda planning to
repaint the front which we feel is much
needed
going into the Town Square and what's
planned in terms of security
improvements as it wasn't very clear on
the response I have
well I'm sure that Steve will have to
take that back and find those answers
but I'm sure that can be put to Adrien
Steve got that chair you're right yeah
if we if we will note the those
additional questions and ask agent to
prepare response okay you will email
well I would like it to be emailed out
to all our committee members okay that's
fine sure yeah okay cancel a Newton okay
can I just suggest that you read through
it by eye item title rather than page
number because so people clearly can't
relate to that and it won't take two
minutes if you just read it through
that's fine I just presumed that
everybody had done a copy of the the
questions and answers and all right well
you should know the page number then
cancel it
I do I'm thinking of other people you're
so considerate okay well okay I'll take
the next one down there
Brunswick more Stephen ten gate I think
you've already answered that W Stephen
yes thanks the response on that
yeah go one borough center same against
even happy with that yeah friendly yeah
go on work-in-progress cancel button -
really buddy scene back I won't go on
okay
right goal one working progress gentle
button again listen about the work of
everybody satisfied with that answer
okay got one working progress council
aims hello oh sorry though
sorry sorry okay Thank You chair yeah
for I speak just a general point about
printing off things the idea I thought
of having things on screen was to save
paper and contribute towards helping the
environment about I've got the question
about cleave word about the affordable
housing percentage I've been answered
it's 20% just just to comment that it's
taurage land and it's a big shame that
tourists can't show that it can fulfil
the for the complete 30% required in the
local plan it's just my comment really
okay Ordnung yes Archer I'm just to
reiterate whatever you say no I mean I'm
like the public unable to see what the
questions and Richard has not given me
anything to go by so when you're saying
that response from his mr. Bowden I'm
blind so I just thought it'd be nice if
we can get up anyway thanks okay we got
down to working progress from council
aims bearing in my tea DC's lower fall
you everybody sorry sorry to butt in I
do think I might be able to try to put
the questions on the screen there yes on
screen John that's called John alright
so I'll go through slowly anybody wants
to know I don't know how this will work
so it's just been done very very quickly
okay are you still on the first page
borough centre Stephen bengi go up on
John John roll
well that's a little bit too far I've
done that there's a slight lag sorry
chose a slight bag tell me where you
want me to go this this is from Janet
Williams this is the second part of that
question about taking action against
landlords yeah that's fine yeah
okay everybody happy with that so and
that goes on keep going John
okay we we've gone to income agenda page
twelve Arbor income that was from me I'm
I'm up about what was said their income
agenda page 12 in upper small increase
on on last year can can everybody see
that yeah okay everybody happy there
nobody's got their anger salaries agenda
page 12 in our per day today's the
budget for building rich buildings is
five thousand nine hundred a week we got
there John yes there will
yeah everybody happy with that anybody
put the only thing I did ask I've got
you okay what did actually ask for is
what is the actual costs I got a budget
right okay
so anybody want to answer that Steve is
or is David still here with us yes I'm
here would you like to answer that David
I think I don't know very much on budget
because the cost we've got a very
residual costs in turn just standing
orders because the building
essentially is up on occupied don't do
it enough we don't penny race because
it's a listed building so we've got some
cost associated with this security
company just go around and check in
probably spend a little bit less than
that 5.9 pounds
I put nine thousand this year okay fine
happy they're in mister Appa signs Thank
You chair okay okay we know on page five
revenue and capital highlights - ginger
page 13 that's me and you mister upper
legal judgment everybody happy with that
answer
does that include you mister offer
that's fine sank right revenue capital
highlights agenda page 16 that's you
again mr. Appa are you happy with that
answer
the problem was got is this got this
problem now what's it gonna be like in
the next couple of years when you look
at the the fact we've actually got a
very high number of people who are
self-employed we've also got the
economists the type of Congress we've
got uh the three highest ones are the
ones that actually causing the most
problem the oecd actually made a comment
the UK economy these are the weakest
points the Recovery's not to be so good
I understand yes we are going to go
through - oh sorry
something else the recovery plan right
it's on the revenue and capital the ifs
and Southampton narratives mr. David
Hayes yes I understand she and I are
looking at it yes as a council should we
be looking at the thing in the long term
was clearly out our finances are going
to be hit not in the short term but in
the long term as well okay Steve would
you like to comment yes yesterday and so
I think at the end of last week I
circulated to members all members
included the the non elected members a
copy of the Devon economic recovery
prospectus so that outlines some of the
economic plans being shaped currently to
deal with kind of the immediate and
shorter term
problems and some of the asks of
government in terms of funding to
resolve those in addition to the funding
packages the government's put in place
to help a variety of businesses so from
that prospectus will develop action
plans so that's the kind of shorter term
towards the the medium term what we then
looking at kind of longer to a picture
is some work we've done is setting up
the the north and Devon futures group
which members will recall Sean McNair
from Patrick came to full council a
short time before we went into lockdown
to outline some of the long-term
longer-term visionary work around that
and the work we'll be doing with North
Devon Council because we'll see quite
clearly we have a anythin an economic
area bigger than just horrid
so that's the kind of work that's being
progressed
okay thanks they in you you happy with
that that's like okay okay we'll move on
there we've just done North Devon
economic strategy every yeah we've done
that
with Chris Fuller's answer yeah
Chancellor Hanes is handwritten oh sorry
alright okay sorry on the long term plan
I mean presumably will have an
opportunity when we revisit the
strategic plan in September for
counselors to put in their contributions
about where we might be going as a
council like you know in terms of
promoting the economy yeah I'm sure I'm
sure that will happen councilor Aames
thank you do you want to make a comment
there Steve I'm Gerry well yes and
absolutely as council him so it was
suggested I see the the strategic plan
was due to go out for consultation
I was just prior to Co bid and obviously
we'll need to reflect the impact of
coltd on that strategic plan and is
something that the leader the deputy
leader and I have been discussing over
that the past couple of weeks in terms
of time in and as counsel Haynes alluded
to we've had kind of September aside
just to have a refresh relook at the
strategic plan in the light of our
financial position which David's base
and the team will be putting together so
they'll all kind of form part of a
package of information for members to
consider thanks Dave and mr. Harper
sorry
I think that's answered my question but
I think that all right your wellness
rundown ya know the one concern I do
have is that we've been talking about
inward investment for such a long time
and we're still waiting to actually have
a plan put into place okay right and I
think also is the fact that we have a
strategy with North Devon which is fine
but I think ABS issues are probably more
Pacific - to us - tores itself okay do
you want to come back there Steve or
anything now chip chair only to say
though obviously for part of our
conversation and discussion with members
of C yes we are two separate council so
our members will have specific views and
we will feed those in where appropriate
into bigger and wider plan so things
around infrastructure
whether it be road rail IT connectivity
are all part of bigger plans so we'll
feed in what we need to into the kind of
bigger strategies and kind of look at
what we need ourselves as well but
they'll be part of our discussion with
members taking place just have just
toward the end of the summer
okay sure Sean cake do you want to say
something are you cheering yeah just
wanted to let you know that only mr.
Harper's point there about in with
investments of Alec one we've been
talking about it for a long time but
there has been a strategy the strategy
has been not necessarily to promote us
forum wide is been to try and grow from
within and we've been quite successful
at leaving in grants we just haven't
been marketing the area quite how some
people think we should now whether that
change is again on Steve's last point
there's something all the members to
debate if we need to direct more
resource to marketing the area
differently as a result of that then
that's what we should look to do there
is also the process of drawing up the
next economic strategy had started
crisis open so there were some broad
headlines that are going to be available
discussion obviously there's being knock
back they might be different or they're
the sense I'm getting at the moment is
that the priority still remain very
similar it's probably the time scale for
deliveries and change so he still wants
to use our natural environment we still
want to protect it look after it we
still want to manage our carbon we'll
still want to support the same sectors
because they haven't changed locally
it's just the needs to do it the time
frame for doing is come in tighter so
that will probably be a resourcing issue
on that but yeah these things are
definitely on a debate later in the year
okay are you okay with that mr. Harper
signs Thanks
okay well I'll move on to TBC three
leader five this was your question in
and we have Sean K to update to be
supplied at this meeting Thank You chair
yes so the leader programs close for you
actions that happened in ended December
last year the it's fully allocated so
not not all of the money has been spent
and I think in the in the report this is
wearing perhaps it's a little confusing
it's sort of knitting to think that
there's a massive under spend on the
program we fully anticipate that all of
the money and more actually because the
team have done such a great job of
delivering program they've been able to
lever in additional funds from Europe
and to deliver the program so buddy by
the end of December this year we'd
expect all the money to be what they
call termed afraid right so that's the
first part and the second part in terms
of the business support that sort of
sort of the other way around on this one
in terms of business support is there a
to again it's a bit confusing the way
it's presented it sort of suggests that
people don't want to take the full 12
hours there's no obligation for people
to take the call twelve hours of
business support so there are two Pro
two offers on the table for them they
can come in take three hours of business
support and we take an output box for
them we're on target for that there then
if they need it and progress and do a
further nine hours of business support
so that they go for twelve again twelve
and there's an output ticked for that
for the North Devon blast when we set
this program out we were expecting
twenty cents of the three our people to
be converted into twelve hours we're
actually achieving fifty percent so the
program is expected to meet all of these
targets exceed its targets and in fact
it's being recognized and given an
extension by them any capsule so yes
it's some comfort for the members there
and that this program is again exceeding
as toggles okay all right here
si okay okay let's move on then I'll be
review mr. Appa you happy with the
answer to that question from David
eighth yeah I would have preferred to
see the complete overheads in other
words sweetener Harbor as a total cost
sensor and I just wonder what that would
show there's a profit or a loss thank
you okay can we move on
actually go to agenda page 17 action TDC
five empty properties Council Lankford
junior counselor Haynes has his hand up
oh sorry no it's just about oh I did
I've just cut it again sorry oh yeah it
was on the previous one about the harbor
I just wondering what progress had been
made my den to find projects in order to
take the harbor back into profit such
situations it says to be a report or
something coming up may I
David are you there David oh yeah I'm
gonna probably think this one's more for
Sean to be honest okay all right I can
pick out yeah I mean to be honest since
since the kovat crisis there hasn't been
an awful lot of progress and moving
forward projects the whole board has
been looking at ways of generating new
income that they're they're fraught with
complications in there we're dependent
on all sorts of external markets and so
we're somewhat in the hands of the the
shippers who do they want to come to
benefit or do they not that that that's
what it comes down to the end of the day
and some of the things that the harbor
were looking at we're having lights
manage moorings differently manage more
moorings to generate income how we might
manage or look its dredging aggregates
from the estuary but again they're
complicated things to achieve and so not
an awful lot of progress has been made
foremost thank
there will be a report from the harbor
board will then at some point I think
charities come back on that one I think
the first thing will be a report to the
harbor board by Richard who's now
looking after the service temporarily
and then for harbor board to make a
recommendation if it wants to try and
push forward an initiative to community
and resources that's a normal process
fine that's fine John okay okay we move
on then go to agenda page 17 empty
properties and this was you cancel
Langford are you happy with that yeah I
just wanted to make sure thank you right
mine was the next one action TV from c5
empty properties well I'm quite happy
with with that answer from Janet okay
that's a really good answer for me right
page oh god is he with us as well
yeah did you want to speak again if
you've got your on don't it's looking
down on us um sorry it's on empty
property is my question here I've only
just got to that Peter yeah right I'll
put my hand up then what measures are
being considered Steve s there's none at
present what did you want to say well
I'm grateful for his reply but it's not
a terribly full reply I just wondering
if any thoughts are being given to
releasing the space above shops for
accommodation for rent whether there's
any measures we can take the council in
terms of incentives or whatever
I know counsel Christy raise this a few
years ago but I don't know quite what
happened I mean are there sort of rate
incentives community charge incentives
business rate incentives if you look
around not just Biddeford in Barnstable
for instance the tops of properties you
see they're empty it's just given the
homeless crisis it seems super the
scandal really hey Steve do you want to
come back on that
there's no incentives I'm aware of
currently and then there's a there's
kind of a disincentive if you like in
terms of council tax charges on empty
properties if you recall through some
work the internal validity did some
years ago those disincentives were put
in place which meant owners of empty
properties had to pay more council tax
than they used to
obviously with a view of trying to
encourage property owners to bring them
back into use rather than leave them
vacant so there's no way of any kind of
incentives to do that because we know
many property owners just leave their
properties vacant because it goes on
this and that there's a number of
related issues around housing and empty
properties over the next cup of
questions - so it looks as though you
know it's one of the one of our
priorities so it looks as though a kind
of larger piece of work I think needs to
be done across this area across
affordable housing then listen questions
around social housing as well over the
next couple of questions okay fidelity
says though it's something that needs to
if something odd features in our current
strategic plan and something that needs
to be kind of developed a little bit
further with members when we review our
strategic plan is it something you
really want to direct resources towards
because as Janet alluded to in her
answer there isn't any dedicated
resources for that type of work
currently but it's not something members
really want to pursue then that so they
would need to look at in terms of
resource in as well as they kind of
weighed a piece of work or on social
housing which kind of features in some
of the questions after these yeah
you know creates all part of a wider
scenario of housing generally but in
terms of the
I street the health of the high street
as well there's talk about releasing
shops for accommodation which presumably
would include above them as a way of
making the high street more viable so I
mean hopefully there'll be central
government action on this as well but
it's something we need to look at anyway
I think okay thank you
just Shaun Kay Thank You chair just yeah
I mean living about the shop there's
been a an aspiration for nearly every
town I've read about in turn census
because people want to bring people back
into to live in town centers to create
vibrancy vitality and all those things
it's fraught with problems especially in
places like benefit because if you you
know traditionally I guess when those
shops were set up the shopkeeper would
live above the shop and that doesn't
tend to happen anymore so quite a lot of
the buildings that you have you have one
entry point so it's a shared entry for a
shop and any accommodation above it it's
difficult to modify the buildings
because of the conservation state it the
the regs are difficult to achieve
because of the safe access [ __ ] in
the event of fire the shop owners quite
often don't want it because the
insurance regulations or implication
sorry but then if you've got people
living above them and there's a fire
risk quite often for their own premises
downstairs so it really is difficult so
coming back on the last point that
Chancellor hangs making changes to plan
well over the years there's been several
different changes in planning to make it
more attractive for people to live about
shops I think what the the latest brand
are and this relates to our work with
the future high streets fun as well as
it's every likelihood that over the last
god knows how many years we've been
trying to protect all retail space in
town centers and there's a realization
that we're probably got we probably got
too much retail accommodation in our
town centers
spread out over two large in area and so
what they're trying to get us to do is
to focus that retail and core town
center activity on a much smaller area
to release the shots on the periphery of
that for residential accommodation now
that's going to take a while it's going
to take all sorts of policy change but
it's certainly something we're looking
at thank you thank you John
okay we'll move on
action td5 empty properties in our per
tv5 TDC five are you happy with that
answer
mr. APPA yes thank you very much it's
just the only thing is that if this is
an annual figure and the total must meet
the cumulative must be quite a
horrendous car right okay we got people
joining useless just join Stacey sorry
they see Dory's just doing the meeting
Jenny
all right okay thank you next one
counsel Lankford asked this question are
you happy counsel Lankford with that
answer yeah I mean if it's okay to just
say something I mean I understand the
answers given and to a certain extent
I'm coming back to something that
Steve's already talked about but I know
it's no good to keep learning the past I
just wish that counsel hasn't been sold
off it may be a simplistic view but
council houses were big enough with big
enough guards to be happy family homes I
bet a lot of people wish they'd houses
like that cheering a lockdown I do feel
I know more now than when I became a
counselor and the only real answer if we
can't find enough affordable houses is
to have our own housing stuff I realize
house may be tied because of national
rules and I don't pretend to understand
all the complications involved I
strongly feel it's something we should
seriously look at and again repeating
something Steve's already said you know
maybe a rethink when it comes to looking
at the strategic plan is necessary about
housing thank you
okay thanks Thank You counseling fee
right Peter Eames yeah on the affordable
housing thing it's obvious that
counselors are very concerned about this
and looking for options like social
housing I've actually put the motion
down for full counts or asking for ok
options be presented I mean it may be
that it will come back to this committee
or something else but I think counselors
counselors want to talk about it and
consider all these options okay right
Castle Newton I just say that I'd like
to strongly support what councilor
Langford has just said yeah and I think
we do need to seriously consider taking
control of these matters into our own
hands and that may well take us back to
having an element or a share in our own
stock so we have control but if we don't
do it the commercial sector is not gonna
do it not to the standard we need it no
no that's true okay
we'll move on then affordable homes
delivered canceled couple and can you
ask this question are you happy with
that reply okay what the others have
been saying we haven't got enough
affordable housing and storage and we
need to do something about it urgently
so I see it's gonna be on the strategic
plan but I think it's something that we
really should focus on one five five
Steve and then Kate are you happy with
that answer thank you
what this is just again an echo of the
other comments but thank you to Ian
modem for the comprehensive question if
he picks up on the point of resources
and the link of resources available and
I think we've already picked up on that
comment but you know if more resources
and they did then that's something
that's going to be looked at
I do wonder if there's a
four step change on housing that we need
to try and help support with in some way
obviously the strategic reviews there
but I don't whether there's a policy
review or something but if we can look
to bring this on to the forward plan and
keep it as a focus that might be our
best starting point you can you can
suggest that when we get to the forward
plan thank you okay
right goal 3 then agenda page 21 waste
review councilor Aames are you happy
with that yes or no well partly well yes
it recognizes that there is a problem
yeah just or underline but you know this
particularly the single plastic thing
this council is part of the anti
single-use plastics campaign it's part
of our carbon plan to reduce it so we
need to hopefully we'll visit this when
we look at our carbon plan again which
will be fairly soon I hope most of our
plastic goes in the say again don't it
with all the beaches Sean Kay you got
your end up mate yeah sure Thank You
chair actually very quickly about
affordable housing I mean talking about
need for policy review I think that
there probably is one of the things
we're picking up is that and you'll be
familiar with this and you work with
plans committee all of the large sites
that are coming through rarely meet
their policy obligations in terms of
affordable housing because if the
infrastructure costs associated with
those sites you know that that then
leads us into a bigger wider question I
think around the allocation of sites in
the local plan and the the amount of
work we should be doing before we
allocate a site to make sure that it is
viable to me these policy obligations so
we need to give that some thoughts and
really serious thought and perhaps
something that I think councillor
James's is either on the call or
listening in he said he's having a
meeting with myself in North Devon to
talk about the local plan and the the
next
working group that's later on today
perhaps that's something we can pick up
with North Devon later on okay I hope so
councilor Aames
yeah picking picking up on that I
believe councillor Christie has asked
for some sort of investigation into the
allocated sites in the local plan in
terms of how much affordable has been
achieved and as Sean says the need to
very carefully assess sites in the
future we can't do it now to determine
what the cost of developing it are
that's got relationships how much
affordable housing you can achieve thank
you move on then
which management measures mr. Harper are
you happy with that question and answer
and more than happy same lovely action
climate change Catholic couple on Kane
are you happy with yes thank you just
leave your aunt permanently on Peter
okay what do you want me to contribute
or don't you wait wait shall I cancel a
couple and Kane are you happy with that
answer yes I'm happy thank you okay
now will you can speak now wait
apologies to councillor Cotter honking
yeah just to clarify that not clarify
add to that Janet Williams is producing
a carbon plan by the end of July and a
meeting a first meeting of the work of
the Working Party of councilors for
climate will be scheduled in the
beginning of August okay right well move
on then next one climate change that's
you again councillor Trotter Lumpkin
are you happy I did I didn't have my
hand up I'm sorry
cancel inch sorry go on there yeah with
these same charging points that we've
got around torij i it mention it before
- sure
- when they're when they're charging
their cars up they have free parking
books father Charlie Torah and I've
noticed that several times that people
put there isn't any signs up saying that
there's free parking while they're doing
what other chores and they're in d'etre
Cara I just wondered if we could put
some signs up and it does make a
difference because you know they're
paying for two or three hours while they
walk around our town and they and and I
thought that we said that while they
were charging her cars it would be free
free parking John can you come back sure
so yeah just to clarify that I think I
meant when we talked about it before
pence their inch I might be mistaken and
I don't think we ever put in the parking
order that would be free chip free
parking so people paying whilst charging
not doing the right thing
okay all right
cancer inch happy with that the item was
just under the impression that he
working in Freeport and that's all sure
okay right I think we got back to you
again castle a couple um Kim about
climate change did you say you're happy
with that answer so does that mean if
you're charging your car using that
point you can get a parking fine if you
haven't got a ticket on it might mean
it's my I hope that wouldn't happen to
have it charged there's a couple of
things that chair so one there's two
charges in place once the charge for
parking the car and the other is the
charge for the electricity you're
putting into the car so that's that's
the two separate things and the that
second part obviously is managed by a
separate company they they installed the
machines on our behalf you know there
and they then take the payment for the
electricity it would require a change of
enforcement regulations in the park in
order for us not to charge that's
something we can look at again later in
the year if we change the part in order
if we wanted to incentivize people to do
that that's something we can do
so let me just get this right on if
because like lucky knows where the
wedding altar where it's got two bays
yeah and and different charges on each
side um so if you park your car there to
charge it up which I don't know I don't
know how long it takes to put a charger
electric car up maybe an hour do you
have to pay to park in that specific Bay
chair it's far as I'm aware yes but let
me let me get the absolute regulations
and stand around to you as a committee
if you like do you want the exact
position because I know the other thing
is you can get a charge notice if you're
parked in those base with a valid paying
display ticket but not hooked up to a
charger but there is a so actually you
know enforcing it the other way around
as well yeah yeah okay so I'll get the
exact position and send it round to the
committee so you can see exactly what we
and can't aren't doing okay okay can I
come in there and just assist
sorry everything cattle okay no yes
chairs the CSS yeah yeah sorry I'm I
don't know everyone's gone but just just
as sis because I I was assisted the team
would not the legal agreements for me
I'm just trying to sort out my screams I
don't know what done but yeah I can't
even save you release so yep we lease
those two cars parking spaces to the
company yeah and the the deal was they
are responsible for the electrical
equipment yeah and obviously they pay
they charge people for the electricity
ant homage will receive some income from
that as well
so we don't actually charge for the car
parking spaces or they we haven't taken
them out of our parking order as yet but
we'll need to because we don't have
control over those areas presently
because that was how we have to do it
to allow the company to put the
equipment in and be responsible for the
equipment okay okay Thank You Stacey
I'm glad you can't turned up now
okay we move on did did I do the one the
climate change
Council cut Lincoln yeah and I was
pleased to see that it's being
publicized quite well that was that okay
let's right we'll go on to this is the
last page you'll all be glad go for
agenda page twenty four action planning
improvement plan and this is from
councilor Aames are you happy with that
answer can for this link each herb right
thank you go for agenda page
twenty-seven action and property
procurement council cut one ken happy
yeah it's fine thanks go for agenda page
28
debt collection mr. Harper I didn't
realize it was a bailiff answer yes very
interesting the government's one of our
debtors oh yeah exactly yeah answer is
any everybody else happy with what
you've seen now and Edie nobody's got
their and up so that must be great we
must be doing something right okay right
we'll move on now there are no more
questions from anybody okay if they
could just yes buddy there's a
recommendation to consider that David
Hayes mentioned at the at the start if
we recall about allocating the the
surplus generated in last year's
accounts yeah I don't know if John can
put that back up that particular bit up
on the screen because obviously I missed
that somewhere so it's a recommendation
to transfer the surplus from 2019 twenty
into the transition in government
funding reserve in order to meet some of
the additional costs and lost income to
encourage nineteen
I I would propose that we recommend that
to say it does we going to see an ardent
that yes chair be a recommendation from
this committee if it's approved and for
C&R so far some anybody I want to
propose that we recommend to say enough
button icon here I'm sorry castle a
Newton you first yeah I propose that
chap okay castle of manly sorry Oh
second man okay okay we'll go we're
going to ask to have a vote for that man
okay
please this time be ready to vote with
your mutant and muting please okay don't
you marry cancer Nakata honkin mr. den
gate or cancer look up for councillor
Haines
counselor Harding for mr. Harper or
cancel the Langford for cancer the manly
Oh cancer inch four counts of Newton
councillor Watson oh yeah that's
unanimous
thank you will that go to next scene our
meeting then Steve and chair yes the the
July meeting okay well at the end of the
end of the moans okay consideration of
the forward plan one thing I would like
to ask all of you is that obviously
we're going to be we are going to have
another meeting when we get qbr one
which is in July late in July
would you all still prefer to have and
leave our meetings while we're doing
soon
for ten o'clock in the morning yeah yes
yeah yeah can I won't be available at
ten o'clock on Tuesday mornings and
right on Tuesday morning on a Tuesday
morning any Tuesday morning
no all right okay jack but you read
today today is the first than the last
that I will be available afraid about a
few changes in life let's just say that
okay okay
but does the majority feel they can that
they we could leave it to 10 o'clock
yeah all those in favor put your hand
upon you think scream see mundane gate
yeah I cancel a new tune counselor Ian
oppor cancel a job counselor our Dean
counselor inch cancel Langford and
obviously I'll go with it
what about counselor Oh Castle come on
King you're not bothered no
Carranza Oh runs up now oh that's fine
okay Pete councilor Aames
aren't you but you are you all right for
10 o'clock yes thank you
yeah but okay right okay I think we can
safely say then that we will have our
meetings while I'm sorry counselor
Manley we'll have our meetings while
we're in in doing virtual meetings at 10
o'clock I mean I don't know what your
situation is definitely but I mean what
all the time would you could do it just
it just out of interest only time after
12:00 we normally have the meetings over
two o'clock or four o'clock and arranged
opportunities around that time change if
I can't make it I can't make it okay all
right
right we'll move on let's get
considerations and forward plan then
where you can see what we've got
wherever the forward plan obviously that
under Beauty aqb eyes the one we're on
Cuba R + 8 + q q 1 is on August the 18th
right
anybody get anything what they put on
the forward plan okay you've got some
hands right oh sorry
right ok well go with you first
Peter Eames hmm yeah I can't even see
you why is your video not on isn't it I
can see myself
he's on Jay yeah I can't see Mitch not
on mine okay um anyway I'll just speak I
think several counselors have said
they'd like to see fordable housing on
the forward plan as I've said I have put
a motion down for full counsel there
could be that would
councilors decide to refer it to this
committee anyway okay okay we'll look at
putting that on the forward plan that's
one on the list right
Stephen dengue thank you just confirm
and said and also I think we probably
need to take off update from external
grants tossing Falls group that's kind
of spent I can tell ya and ethical
investments we should really change to
ESG as I mentioned earlier I wonder if
there's a value in combining that
alongside the revered Treasury
investment options because they're
fairly broadly in line with each other
and also that would be investment policy
for and coach District Council as part
of that so there's a general overarching
the new event okay right
okay mr. Harper I have our several times
for but perhaps the peer review to have
a look at the peer review again okay
well we'll make a list of all these
counselor Inc Thank You chair
yeah just generation report you know
that task and finish group is that all
been done away with there we still meet
I don't remember the last time we met
that that I don't think a dummy's still
Metheny income generation or we still do
I don't think we've ever disbanded it
Deborah Steve we didn't it's still
running really into it and saying yes we
haven't we haven't disbanded it mostly
have met for quite a period of time now
I think the last time we just updated
all the outputs and outcomes from all
the things that the committee has
recommended to see an arm full council
and so forth and whatever mores around
Treasury options Treasury investment
options
chair so we can have a look
by some other thing you said it was
still outstanding from that working
group yeah and said something up
probably the near future right okay we
can do that so we've we've got there a
few things now to to go on to our local
plan which will we'll organize and put
on there and so is everybody happy
hello any more questions from anybody
well that's it and I must thank you for
all for all coming and being patient and
I think we I think we've done I
hopefully we've done a good job maybe be
good to look back on on YouTube and see
how you all did okay so until the next
time thank you all for coming and
turning them okay yeah Thank You chair
thank you thank you